المباراه الثانيه البارزه له كانت ضد اكبر
منافسا ليونايتد انذاك وهو فريق ارسنال بث
رونالدو في هذه المباراه ايضا طاقه جديده
في الفريق واحرز هدفين مساعدا يونايتد في
الفوز على منافسه الاكبر باربعه اهداف
مقابل هدفين على ارض الخصم كان رونالدو قد
بدا يصبح اللاعب المفضل لدى الجماهير في
مانشستر واكثر لاعب معروف في كره القدم
الانجليزيه لكن مع اقتراب كاس العالم 2006
تحول من محبوب الجماهير الى شرير في
مباراه واحده
مع بدء كاس العالم للعام 2006 كان
كريستيانو رونالدو بالطبع قد اصبح معروفا
في ارجاء انجلترا واوروبا ايضا كواحدا من
اعظم اللاعبين في العالم وكانت هناك حاله
الترقب هائله لما سيقدمه في كاس العالم
وكان هناك بالطبع صراع محتدم بين انجلترا
والبرتغال في ربع النهائي رونالدو ضد روني
زميله في مانشستر يونايتد وتصدمت القارتان
في شكل حتمي ولا ينسى بالتاكيد
هو الذي تسبب بخروج روني توا
اثار ذلك تساؤلات عن قدره رونالدو وروني
على اللعب معا في ملعب اولد ترافورد بعد
الحادثه حقيقه بدا ان الامر قد يتحول الى
عداوه شديده ضمن غرفه تبديل الملابس في
اولد ترافورد وكان لذلك تاثير هائل بالطبع
في رد فعل المشجعين الانجليز على رونالدو
فقد تولدت فجاه عداوه نحوه لم تكن من قبل
فحتى داعموا النوادي الخصوم كانوا قد
تقبلوا على مضد انهم يشاهدون لاعبا عظيما
ومن المرجح انهم استمتعوا كثيرا بمشاهده
لاعبه رغم انه كان يهزم فرقهم هزيمه ساحقه
وفجاه اصبح رونالدو يقابل بهتافات
الاستنكار اينما ذهب وبدا ان بعض مشجعي
مانشستر يونايتد انقلبوا ضده
وقد تطلب التجاوز ذلك الموسم قوه شخصيه
هائله من قبل رونالدو حتما حيث تحول الى
شرير الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز في شكل
مبالغ فيه